Paco is really excited
about what he's heard
about the benefits he'll receive
from making his application
with Google App Engine.
Since he's not familiarized
with the platform,
he decides to start from zero
with the most basic application,
an application that shows
the home page or landing page
to users upon accessing.
This way he'll become familiar
with it and begin to develop it
with a solid foundation.
THE GOOGLE APP ENGINE SDK
Before beginning to develop
the first thing Paco needs to do
is download and install
SDK on his computer:
Google App Engine
"Software Development Kit."
It's a software package
with different tools
that will allow him
to interact with the platform
during the entire lifecycle
of his application.
It's possible that Paco
and his work team
use computers with different
operative systems
during application development.
This is not a problem,
since SDK
is adapted for the different
operative systems,
Windows, Mac or Linux.
As for programming language
or run time,
they are currently supported
by Google App Engine,
Python 2.7, Java 7
and languages run by JVM,
Php 5.4 and Go.
Paco has always been
a big fan of Python
and wants to use it
for this project.
Not just because
he's familiar with the language,
but because it offers coverage
for the majority
of platform services.
The only prerequisite
is having Python SDK installed.
Paco is ready to continue
with the installation.
But what exactly
does SDK include?
A local web server
that allows us
to run the applications
on our computers.
A tool that allows us
to upload local code
to the production environment.
A process known as deploy.
Personal APIs and libraries
that offer programming access
to Google App Engine services.
Third-party libraries,
included because they are
dependents of Google App Engine
personal libraries
or because they are usually used
for developing
most applications.
Applications or additional tools
that help
the development process.
Optional integration
with Integrated Development
Environment (IDE),
specifically for Java runtime
an official plug-in
for Eclipse is included.
Keep in mind that
even though SDK runs locally,
it's in charge
of closely emulating
the Google App Engine
production environment.
So you will notice
that resources are restricted
to those that won't have access
or features that won't
be available to the sandbox.
For example:
access to the file system
or the system's
low-level features.
SDK code is open.
And it is frequently updated
with new characteristics
and improvements
to existing features.
APPLICATION STRUCTURE
AND BASIC COMPONENTS
With SDK installed,
Paco is ready
to develop his application.
As with any web application,
this implies
having a small part
of the configuration
in a file called
app.yaml,
plus a file with the content
that will initially be shown
in the application,
a simple, landing page.
In the file app.yaml,
Paco will define
the basic configuration
of his application.
By using an application
written in Python,
the yaml format will be used
in the following fields:
Application:
used to assign
a unique identifier
to the application.
Version:
defines the name of a code
version of the application.
Google App Engine
allows there to be
various versions of the
application at the same time.
Runtime:
corresponds to the name
of the execution environment
used to run our application.
In Paco's case,
we will use the runtime
python27.
Api_version:
specifies the API version
that we will use
for a determined runtime.
There currently exists a unique
API for the Python runtime.
Threadsafe:
configures our application
so that every instance
is able to execute
concurrent processes,
we normally use the "true" value
in Python applications.
Handlers:
define expressions
that allow URLs to be assigned
to the scripts
that will attend
to the http applications.
We can also define routes
that will deliver
static HTML files,
CSS style pages,
Java scripts or images,
among others.
For any App Engine application,
the mentioned fields
will be obligatory.
For the application
with the census landing pace,
Paco will define two handlers.
The route /index.html
will directly serve
the index.html file
with the landing page content.
All the content whose route
begins with /assets
will be served as static files
from the static file
of the application.
Paco copies an image file
with the census logo,
called logo.png,
in the static file,
which has an HTML reference.
THE DEVELOPMENT SERVER
After finishing with the files,
Paco feels very anxious
and wants to see
that everything
really works as hoped.
To do this, he uses
a very important component
that is included with the SDK,
the development web server.
This will allow him to execute
his application locally,
before unfolding it.
In other words,
the development server
is ideal for testing
and validating the application's
general behavior.
To start the local
development server
Paco has three alternatives:
use Google App Engine Launcher
a GUI available for Linux,
Mac and Windows,
the dev_appserver.py command
through the command line,
or an IDE.
Eclipse and Pycharm
offer plug-ins
to directly complete
this action.
LET'S GET TO WORK!
Launching the local server
using the launcher
is very simple.
Paco adds the file
that contains his application
and then just clicks
on the "Run" button.
The local server will start
serving his application
in port 8080.
Alternatively
the personal terminal
to his operative system opens
and is located in
the application root directory,
where the app.yaml file
is also located.
Paco writes
the following command.
Upon starting, the local server
sees messages in the terminal
that indicate the port
where his application launched.
To see his landing page
in the development web server,
Paco enters the URL address
localhost:8080,
from any navigator.
Upon entering,
a GET application is created
to the root route, slash,
and it is answered
with the content index.html file
described in the prior section.
This way Paco validates
that the content
shown on the navigator
corresponds to the landing page,
including the logo image
in /assets.
Paco could
launch the application
and did tests
on his local machine.
Now it's your turn to experiment
with the repository
and launch the landing page.
In the following lessons,
we will review the steps
necessary to publish
on Google App Engine.
Keep programming.